[Music]
hello everyone
my name is kevin chug and i'm a
professor at the university of texas at
arlington
i'm very excited to be here today to
tell you a little bit about the research
we've been doing on uh hemp
low thc cannabis specifically in this
case using liquid chromatography
and tandem mass spectrometry to look at
anthocyanin flavonoids
those molecules that give the plants the
various different colors
and how those vary between different
cannabis cultivars
i want to first uh you know recognize
[Music]
mike pecor as he is
one of my students who's done the
majority of this work this is a picture
of my group from the not too distant
past
and also the the collaboration with zed
therapeutics
for providing the hemp and conducting
some of the
time course study that i'll talk about
at the end
so let's get going
i'm just going to very quickly
uh
review some typical
general cannabis analysis right just to
remind you of
the analytical techniques that are used
commonly and then we'll go into talking
specifically about lcms and its
application to looking at these
anthocyanin flavonoids
and ultimately looking at those inside
the different hemp cultivars
so i think anybody who's been you know
in and around the cannabis industry
knows that there's a very standard set
of methods that are commonly needed to
be applied for quality control of
cannabis and and this just starts simply
with you know being able to measure
moisture
um obviously uh the the main bioactive
compounds in these plants are the
cannabinoids that we're interested in
and
the various different plants have
various different levels and you know we
have low thc hemp and high thc cannabis
and so we need to be able to
analyze the potency of these plants so
that's typically done using hplc so
liquid chromatography the uv detector
it's also common to want to look at
terpenes these are also bioactive
compounds that convey the you know
flavors and fragrances of the
cannabis plant
and that's mainly done with gas
chromatography with the fid detection
pesticides gets a little bit more
complicated we need a little bit more
power with our analysis in order to
really see trace levels of these
pesticides
and different pesticides may be more or
less amenable to using gas
chromatography or liquid chromatography
but again typically needing mass
spectrometer there for more specificity
and sensitivity in the detection
uh depending on your state uh
obviously we we should hope that people
are testing these things uh regularly
and
across the nation but
the use of things like icp mass spec for
metals analysis
and a variety of you know typical
biochemical methods would be used to
look at the
contamination of of plants by
microorganisms like mold and bacteria
okay so
that's kind of the landscape that you
all are interested in and used to using
i'm going to go a little bit more depth
into a technique
called liquid chromatography tandem mass
spectrometry uh this is a technique that
uses a
let's see a fancier mass spectrometer uh
a triple quadrupole mass spectrometer
the combination of these techniques
really is already the gold standard for
trace quantitative analysis in a lot of
areas including clinical analysis
looking as we've already mentioned
pesticides but
labs use these things very regularly to
to interrogate biological species
peptides lipids in in very complex
mixtures this is a really highly precise
and efficient
separation technique for
non-volatile and semi-volatile compounds
coupled to a detection technique
that gives you very good sensitivity
and very good specificity and i'll
elaborate on that a little bit more
the front end of the the instrumentation
uh is is your hplc and and really this
is not much different than what you
might see in these more simplified let's
say cannabis analyzer here this is a
product that shimatsu provides
where we have the ability to inject very
small volume extracts
we have a system where we have high
pressure pumps delivering a mobile phase
that allows you to separate the
compounds as they pass across
a stationary phase
in this case
usually something like a c18
functionalized particle packed in this
10 centimeter long column and as i said
typically uh uv vis detection is good
enough for potency analysis
but when we really want to go and look
at the
things more in depth
and at lower levels we need to be
considering a different detector and so
the triple quadruple detector here
features an electrospray ionization
interface this is the way that we
convert
molecules
in the in the liquid phase into gas
phase ions they need to be in the gas
phase
for us to manipulate them in the mass
spectrometer and then i mentioned tandem
mass spectrometry this just refers to
our ability to
take those ions once they're in the gas
phase and fragment them further to learn
more about them it's kind of like you
know taking apart a jigsaw puzzle these
things will break at different points
and we can use those fragmentation as a
kind of diagnostic tool to characterize
the molecules so overall
you know we have
we can operate this instrument in many
different ways
and we're going to utilize a several of
these techniques as we go forward
so looking up you know if you were to
look under the hood of this triple
quadrupole mass spec uh
what you see is what you might expect
you know three quadruples um and they
are arranged here in this schematic
where we have the electrospray
ionization source
uh you have a single first quadrupole
that allows you to select different ions
or scan across a range of ions
the second quadrupole is used
exclusively
to induce collisions to fragment the
ions of interest and then we can use the
third quadrupole to sort those fragments
so for example a really common
way to use this technique would be to
use what's called a product ion scan
so if you see there on the left we have
this mixture of
m plus ions that are fed into the first
quadrupole
we we're interested in just one of these
this m2 plus so we tell it to select
that ion maybe it has a massive charge
at 450. it goes in the second quadrupole
and is fragment in the different
fragments these are these puzzle pieces
and then we can use those that third
quadrupole to sort of sort those puzzle
pieces and generate a mass spectrum that
would be diagnostic of that initial
product of interest so this is gives us
good qualitative information about an
ion of interest
this is a
you know the same type of approach at
least with the first quadrupole is
utilized when we go into multiple
reaction monitoring mode and this is
really where uh the power of a triple
quad mass spectrometry comes for
quantitative analysis this multiple
reaction monitoring mode allows really
great sensitivity and specificity
so
just like the last one we have this
mixture of ions
we use the first quadripole to select an
ion of interest this is called the
precursor ion
um so that's the molecule you know we
may be interested in quantifying
and when we develop the method what
we'll do is we'll fragment that through
q2 generate a set of fragments and then
pick a particular fragment for the third
quadrupole to monitor specifically
when we do this we are operating in the
most sensitive manner for these
quadrupoles so when we have it sit and
look at a specific ion at one time this
is the most
sensitive way that we can utilize this
instrument when we scan across multiple
ions we do lose some sensitivity
now in this case because we're measuring
a specific product of a specific
precursor ion that we've chosen we gain
lots of specificity because there's not
likely many other things in that mixture
that would generate that diagnostic
product time
additionally the extra sensitivity comes
because we really reduce a lot of noise
from the analysis with this kind of
triple
um filtering mechanism that we have in a
triple quadrupole so that effectively
that lowering of the noise allows us to
have a higher signal to noise ratio
uh which is you know what we're looking
for for quantitative analysis
one other uh approach that's used with
these instruments that's really less
utilized is what's called a precursor
ion scope scan mode
and this is a bit different this is used
to discover molecules in the mixture
that have common fragments so
in the in the previous two we we just
told quadrupole 1 that we're only
interested in one ion but in this one
we're just going to have quadrupole 1 to
sort our ions in order of increasing
mass to charge ratio and then each one
of those as it comes through the first
quadrupole is subjected to fragmentation
and creates its own series of fragment
ions
but we tell quadrupole 3 we're only
interested in seeing molecules that
generate a particular fragment in this
case this f2 plus you know something
that has a massive charge of 335.
so we will only register a signal at the
detector
when something comes through
and is fragmented and generates this 335
ion so we choose this ion to be
something diagnostic of let's say a
class of compounds that we're interested
in seeing and then by running in this
mode we can now go and see if there's
something in the sample that generates
this fragment ion when it does
that fragment ion is timed with the same
we can go back through and look and see
what came through the first quadrupole
in order to figure out what that was so
i'm going to be using these type of
modes a little bit as we go further into
the story
let's first talk a little bit more about
flavonoids
these are ubiquitous plant secondary
metabolites that exist in virtually
any natural product
they exist in a very wide range of
structures that are all built from this
kind of central a b ring structure
which can be combined in different ways
and i think you've you probably have
heard of some of these flavonoids before
a lot of these are very desirable uh
nutrient products for for various
reasons we're going to focus in on the
the anthocyanide then that one up in the
middle right top
as a particular flavonoid that confers
color to plants but it has other
benefits as well
the anthocyanin
refers to the compound where you have an
anthocyanin the parent flavonoid
structure and then it has appended some
different groups there on the bottom in
this case indicated by that glycoside
and acyl group
so these really are what provide the the
reds the blues purples
some yellows in into a lot of different
plants
they should not be confused some some
plants confer plant pigments mainly
through things like carotenoids which
are present in carrots
you can get some similar coloring from
these different classes but carotenoids
and anthocyanins are very different
in their
chemical properties
these anthocyanins are well known to
have antioxidant capabilities and in
some cases have been
reported to have really significant
benefit in treatment of different uh
diseases
now um kind of looking closely to to
better understand the the diversity and
complexity of this system um you see
here that that just general structure on
the left and on the right
you see parent
so that top part of the left structure
these are different pieces that could
form different chemical species
that we might see
and if you look at the b ring the top
right ring of each one of these
structures you'll see that the
substituents vary you see you know one
you know deltana does three hydroxyl
groups cited in two pallar gardened in
one
pionen has a hydroxyl group and a
methoxy group and so already
we can see how the diversity of this
chemical class can vary just based on
the substitution of that ring
and then we'll see later
we can append a very wide variety of
different glycosidic groups onto these
bottom hydroxyls
to create different anthocyanins
the anthocenants uh as i said are
pigments um that pigmentation is
dependent on the the chemical structure
of of the anthocyanin that's present
paranthocyanins it's generally a mixture
of them
um
these are known to even you know chelate
with metals and things so there's a lot
of things in the solution that can
modulate
the colors that they confer
in this case on the right we're just
showing how the ph
of the of the medium can affect the
color
the anthocyanins are generally stable at
lower phs below six and above there you
can have some irreversible
changes into what's shown at the bottom
there in the bottom right this chalcone
group so but even in in the ranges of
low to medium ph uh we can see
significant color changes for different
anthocyanins if we were to expose them
to different environments and they are
present in different environments inside
uh the plant
so
this just gives you a kind of feeling
for how these molecules can change about
and change their color now we have i've
had a lot of interest in anthocyanins
for a long time we've done quite a bit
of research in the past
just to give you kind of feeling
blueberries are really highly rich in
anthocyanins we can take blueberries
lyophilize them which means basically
freeze dry them
extract them with some acidic you know
alcoholic mixture
and then we can take these to our lc or
lcms for analysis and in this case you
know not the best separation but i you
know i think you can appreciate the
complexity of a mixture here
uh
where we have you know 25 or so
different anthocyanins that are present
in this blueberry
and those are listed with their
structures on the right you'll see again
these things are depicted as having
not the structures but the names on the
right depicted as having the anthocyanin
and then where the appended glycosidic
bond is that can be at these three or
five positions
again i'll show you a little bit more of
that a little bit later
we we worked with uh we worked with a
company out of new york on this study
that makes freeze-dried berries and we
said okay well once you you send us some
of your freeze-dried berries i mean we
could probably show that the
anthocyanins are you know massively
concentrated as you you pull down pull
out these uh
the water from these blueberries and it
could be a good you know marketing for
you
but when we did the analysis uh what we
found was
that the the fresh blueberries whether
they were cultivated wild
had much much higher anthocyanin content
than the ones that they had dried and or
sweetened
so yeah this was kind of adverse to what
they wanted to see and ultimately they
asked that we didn't include their name
in the publication and i understand uh
but we still appreciate that they
played ball with us and it was
interesting to see so
if you're looking at whether to eat you
know your fresh blueberries or your
dried and sweetened blueberries from
nutritional standpoint of the
anthocyanins and the antioxidants go
with the fresh stuff
okay
moving on uh
i told you we're using this tandem mass
spectrometry and and we're interested in
uh
being able to find anthocyanins in these
cannabis plants
and so we're going to make use of the
well characterized fragmentation that
can occur in tandem mass spectrometry
when we use those different
fragmentation modes
and this just shows you
how different ways that a particular
anthocyanin can fragment so on the left
the easiest things to knock off these
different
glycosidic groups these these sugars
that have been appended at the three and
five position and those fall off pretty
easily sometimes even just during
electrospray ionization
that will leave you with the residual uh
anthocyanin den
which can further undergo different
fragmentation based on let's say loss of
small molecules or crosslink ring
cleavages
often referred to as as a retro deals
alder and this is just a formalism
that allows you to name different
fragments for these things based on
which fragment contains the the charge
after the fragmentation is complete so
no need to go into great detail here
but just to make it look uh quite
complex
here for cyanodyne are showing some of
the fragments that you can generate on
the left based on this retro diels alder
cross ring ring cleavage mechanism or on
the right uh based on this small
molecule loss and i think that that the
key takeaway take home here is is that
we know the mass to charge ratio those
numbers associated with each one of
those fragments and so we can go looking
for those in our sample
and and have them be somewhat diagnostic
of this particular molecule if it's
present
and obviously if we see more than one
fragment that's that's even better
uh evidence
uh just again to show you if we were to
take do a product ion scan
for these molecules where we just take
those parent anthocyanidins
on the top cyanodyne and the bottom
polygonidine
and and you apply these to fragment them
and just see what kind of fragments are
formed
what you'll see is a whole bunch of
signals uh throughout the mass spectrum
that conform to those different
fragmentation mechanisms that i saw and
so it's a very rich pattern of
information
again you can think of this as a
fingerprint that we could use to
identify those molecules in the plant if
they are present
okay so let's get into the hemp here
we have worked together with zed
therapeutics these is a group
out of
oregon eugene oregon
and they provided us with a number of
low thc hemp samples
very you know pretty looking stuff at
least well i guess when they harvest it
i didn't take these pictures you know we
get sent them after they've been dried
and cured and they don't look quite as
impressive
but but from the start yeah we can see
that there's some significant variation
in the colors in these in these
different hemps
we'll take these uh samples and we
subject them to a cryo mill
which allows you just on you you can
basically put them in this chamber it
has a you know big ball bearing there in
the middle and then we cool this whole
thing down with liquid nitrogen and just
shake it up and and basically pulverize
this sample down into a very fine powder
so you get very high surface area for
extraction
so these cryo mills are very nice and
versatile for preparing samples for
extraction because they can make nice
such small particle sizes
we take those uh and then take them and
extract them we're just using a mixture
of methanol and water with a little
trifluoroacetic acid
we did find that because you co-extract
some different waxes
that those could have
some delicious effect on the separation
downstream so what we end up doing is
taking those extracts and de-fatting
them a little bit by extracting that
with hexane
so we just you know pulling the fats off
into the hexane and leaving behind these
water-soluble anthocyanins
and you can see here
these extracts and just get a little
initial first appreciation for at least
here lenny sherbet and cattail grape
the different color that you can get
from that extract
so we know that there's anthocyanins in
there
we just have to go find them so an
example of our strategy would be to go
looking for cyanogen um
and so we we have maybe this parent you
know cyanine iii glucoside
and we know if if it loses this
glycosidic bond in the middle that we
can expect a massive charge of 449
and then if we go further we can you
know expect some other fragments these
crosslink ring cleavages and whatnot of
some other massive charges that we can
look for
so we set our precursor ion scan
so you can see here in the top left uh
the schematic where we've got our first
quadrupole scanning from 250 to 850 mass
charge and we're just interested in a
signal if something comes through and
gives us a signal for 287 mass charge
which is the parent ion for cyanogen and
when we do that we get so we get this
signal this chromatogram on the bottom
and there's this big hump signal around
12 and a half minutes and then when we
go back and look at the first quadrupole
to see what makes this we get the mass
spectrum up at the top right and what we
see there is a dominant signal
at 3 611
mass to charge and this indeed
corresponds to
a three cyanogen three five diglucide so
we have uh glycoglycosides attended to
both the three and the five position on
this particular anthocyanin and that
appears to be
quite a dominant
anthocyanin present in this
sample
now
the precursor ion scan is nice for
looking for things but as i said because
we're operating part of this instrument
in a scan mode it's not as sensitive
but we can go now to try to like do
things to make it more sensitive first
let's confirm
uh that we're really seeing this
molecule and we can generate fragments
from it that would be diagnostic what
we'd expect
so we can go and do now a
product ion scan where we tell the first
quadrupole only send through when you
see ions of of 611 massive charge that's
the cyanogen35 diglecocide and now let's
use the fragmentation to break this
thing apart and see what it deforms so
we see a signal
whenever we get this thing coming
through again
the methods changed a little bit so this
the time is a little bit different here
um but when we see the 611 come through
we can fragment it and then we can see
that we generate a series of diagnostic
fragment ions
that are um consistent with that cyan
and then three five day glucoside and
then can say okay indeed that this is a
quite a large species in the anthocyanin
now
ultimately we we did this i'm not gonna
go ad nauseam but we did this for a
whole bunch of different anthocyanins
and and these as i told you there's
different you know anthocyanin parents
and there's different types of appending
groups and what we did is built out a
whole series of
multiple reaction monitoring schemes
for each series of different antho for
each anthocyanin and so now you see the
chromatogram in the middle this is from
an extract to the cattail grape each one
of those different colors
is a different anthocyanin that we've
basically created a uh precursor to
product ion transition uh those two
filled circles were just having our our
first and our third quadrupole look for
specific ions that are consistent with
those different anthocyanins and and i
think you can see off the bat there's a
lot of anthocyanins in there and in fact
what we can do is
look at that a little bit more
holistically and show that we have you
know
pretty large component of let's say
three major anthocyanins and then let's
say lesser amount of some of the other
ones
if we do the same thing now let's say
compare it to now black licorice black
licorice appears you know it's got this
really deep kind of purplish darkish
color
really seems to be rich in a lot of
different anthocyanins i mean even now
approaching some of the levels of things
like blueberry which okay also has a
very deep rich purple color so
um
these deep colors
gender mean a more richness of
anthocyanin uh we can also project this
as a as a as a pie chart as before and
you can see maybe a little bit more
interesting distribution of some
different
uh anthocyanins than we had with the
cattail grape uh
and and some different different
distributions so we're just starting to
now learn kind of what's in these things
and and
hopefully we'll be able to parse that
out further
you'll notice that there are a number of
things that are say the same thing right
on the top right you see del sent it in
611 they'll send it in 465 they'll send
it in 435
i just want to show you very quickly
what what's happening there right so we
have this parent delfinitin which is
defined based on having those hydroxyl
groups in that those positions
uh 303 and then
if we append one glucoside at the three
position this gives us a massive charge
of 465 so that's our definitive 465
or if we append a a rabbinoside so it's
a little bit different than the
glycoside which gives us a different
massive charge of 435 so completely
different species but just because it
has this different side chain and
there's other ones so here's a routine
of side you know a little bit longer
appended chain
and then you know as i've shown already
we can have these diglycocides where you
have substitutions of three and five
position and so any of these single
substitutions could also occur at the
five position although the three
position is is more common
or you can also have multiple
uh uh linkages of these glycosides at
both of the points and so this really
increases the complexity of the system
as you can imagine
uh you know last one uh here before i
show you kind of a more grand comparison
but lenny sherbert
you know gives us you know nice really
red color
um and so interestingly enough the
the anthocyanin profile is not so
complex this is a cyanodyne uh primarily
which okay cyan is named for that red
color
but just to show you kind of the the
comparison at least for these uh five
different
um
hemp varietals and and and uh you can
see the colors that are extracts and in
each one of these signals again is a
specific anthocyanin and so there's some
significant overlap and some significant
differences but again i think this is
really the first time anybody's really
looked at trying to characterize these
colors uh chemically uh by profiling the
anthocyanins like this
so before i uh
leave this completely i just want to
alert you some upcoming work
that's going to be reported out here
very soon
we've been working with zed therapeutics
as well as with curtis mathis grow
lights
and nanova environmental to conduct a
study where we looked at the effect of
different lighting on on the
uh production by production of bioactive
compounds by you know four different
hemp varietals
and so uh just briefly what we have here
is four tenths setup uh tent one uses a
high
high power white light led 1212
temp two white light just you know with
a lower power
temp 3 and 10 4 modulate in different
amounts of a a particular red led and
the idea here is to perform some
phytochrome manipulation and understand
how inducing or changing this red light
introducing this red light might affect
the
expression of different bioactive
molecules
so the the nano environmental was very
interesting it's a portable
gc instrument and we just basically
hooked this thing up to the tenths and
over time we're collecting data for a
whole series of terpenes and this is
hard to see but um just suffices to say
you know tent one two three four from
the left and these are these different
colors are showing the expression of
different
um anthocyanin i'm sorry terpenes over
time he's a terpene expression
and we do see some significant variation
in the terpene expression now these
terpenes would be
a mass expression from the four
different genetics that are in the tent
um and and later at the end we were
doing a comprehensive protein analysis
the individual plants um
but you know there's so you see some
variation in terpene profiles from the
different lighting um there's also some
significant variation although not as uh
as
drastic
on some of the cannabinoid
uh content in in its uh production
uh but you know
what we see are i mean really just
amazingly different looking plants that
we can generate from some of these
uh
from some of these things put under
different lighting conditions
we're still working through the
anthocyanin data but just to show you
for here here's three different types of
hemp
uh b73 b120 246 and these are
been grown under the different lighting
conditions and you can see now these are
cyanide and routine aside and pioneered
in retinocides the two of the higher
uh higher abundance anthocyanins and we
can see how they vary with the different
lighting conditions in the tents
and we're working to parse this out a
little bit further looking at the full
anthocyanin profile and we'll be
submitting a publication on this soon so
as i mentioned in one of the previous
slides or at least it was set up there
you can actually follow this research on
linkedin by
following my my good friend and
collaborated dr zach hildenbrand
so just you know this is just the
beginning of looking at the hemp color
palette um there's obviously
uh like to apply this across a wide
range of genetics also would like to be
able to widen the net to look at other
you know beneficial flavonoids
the lighting study i think is a really
interesting add-on and
should provide another tool for
people cultivating hemp to modulate the
bioactive components
um
you know we have started looking at
wider range of things in this hemp but
you know we got to start some place and
anthocyanins certainly are an
interesting uh area to look at because i
think everybody can appreciate the
the very color interesting colors that
these plants can can take
so i would just uh like to end by by
thanking uh collaborators dr zach
hildenbrand adam jacques and christian
west of zed therapeutics uh we've also
gotten a lot of support from shimazu
scientific instruments and restek
corporation
and i want to thank
lab roots conference for the opportunity
to
present this work
thanks very much for your attention
you